Welcome everybody to another zoom call and remember if you have questions, use the chat and just chat those questions in
Have a bunch of questions that came in and remember if you do have questions
Before the zoom call go to the zoom page
under the member site and you can type in your question and
That's what we're going to be answering here in just a minute
Always remember that we'll try to keep up to date with any announcements on the member site and then you can schedule
Or any visits you need to make
All right, so
Let's get to the
First question I
Had an MRI done as my cancer antigen numbers
Keep going up. So first of all defining terms
Cancer antigen numbers are your tumor marker numbers
Keep going up my brain is clear
I presume that means the MRI showed the brain is clear, but shows signs of bone metastasis
So I presume this person is saying their MRI is showing signs of bony metastasis
Negalace is up. Negalace is a test. It's a totally different for tests. Negalace numbers are up a
Small bit, but still in the normal range. I
Was it was in my spine to begin with yet had gone invisible
I assume that
Your meeting that
The metastasis was in your spine to begin with, but that wasn't visible
On some scan maybe the MRI maybe a pet scan. I'm not sure
So if this person is on you may want to reformulate that to help us understand that a little bit
Beed it is showing again. What do you suggest for changing up?
Again, I'm not fully understanding that it's that the tumor marker has elevated so
Remember you don't you don't make come you don't make
Decisions based upon just one test. So if the tumor marker is elevated yet that MRI is clear
I don't I'm not exactly sure what
How to understand this, but in general if you're going to if you're going to make some changes in your protocol based upon
your
Objective or subjective findings changing. So if you have a change in objective findings
Like the you know, there's different markers that are showing a greater degree of metastasis or
Something like that or you're not feeling as well your teeth is increased you have increased in pain along with some blood test changes
etc. Then yeah, it's always good to check to see if we should change things up
So do we need to change the rife settings maybe do we need to is there a best healing journey for the bones?
What could you do for that? So let's kind of walk through this
So number one one way that you can change things up and know to what you should do to change things up
Would be to do another jigswap test. So through another jigswap test and we could look at your protocol
Dietary protocol supplement protocol to see if we need to change things up
We also will see if we need to change the rife settings
You also make decisions on changing the rife settings based upon
Other things too. So first of all
If you want to add some bone healing programs to your rife
Anybody can message me and ask for those I wrote a new bone set
Program it's some short programs for for bone building if that's if you have metastasis to bone and you have
Body involvement those could be helpful
But again, I always think that it's best to run the cancer programs because the reason why you have
Arrosion of a bone if you have metastasis to bone is because the cancer so it's not about just we need to build up the bone and
Get counseling into the bone and get the bone healed. We need to kill the cancer. It's causing the destruction
Are there some nutritional things in general that are good to help build bone?
Yes, of course you always think of calcium to build bone
But I think it's a mistake when people are taking high dose calcium
So when you have an increased bone loss either due to osteoporosis or osteopidia that is not pathological
Or you have pathological bone loss because of metastasis to bone and body
Destruction because most metastasis to bone is going to be
Is going to be lidic maybe it's going to be breaking down bone
You first state that we need to really increase the calcium we need to be taking a thousand fifteen hundred milligrams of calcium and
The studies are shown that that's not the right thing to do you really need to increase a
Type of vitamin K called vitamin mk4 now a lot of vitamin K's on the market are
Going to be the mk7 mk7 is a general
Absorption of calcium. That's what vitamin K does
But it's mk4 that gets them calcium into the bone
So we have a product out there that's called osteo K
osteo
E bone dash K and it's very high dose mk4
With just I think a couple couple capsules is like 250 or something milligrams of calcium
So it's really the right dose of calcium with very high doses of mk4
So if you have destruction of bone for any reason whether it's non pathological osteoporosis osteopidia
Or it's pathological meeting that you have destruction because of
Metastasis to bone then taking osteo K is the right thing to do
It's the right dose of calcium with the correct dose of mk4
There is no other supplement of the market that has that a lot of mk4
We still have a bone-building bundle we still have a bone-building bundle
It also has a couple other supplements that it's really good for the bone which is
The TVGO the TVGO is
EGCG supplement why would you take EGCG for bone-building because it decreases
Inflavation at the periosteum, so that's why you would take that
I can't remember what else is in that bundle, but
It's really that osteo K to help build bones and
TVGO are the two most important ones
Next question I have been having trouble sleeping my watch
I think this person must have like an apple watch that monitors their sleep
It gives them what's called a sleep score
My watch has been scoring me in
32 to mid 50s
And my normal sleep score was in the 80s
So for those that don't have one of those apple watches with the sleep score on it
That
I think it's 80 and above is good anything less than that is considered not good
So what that does is it monitors how many times you're waking up during the night at monitors
I think it may monitor your heart rate it may monitor a few other things and it gives you a sleep score based upon
the things that it is
Now firstly, I'm not a big fan of using an apple watch or one of those watches at all
I mean, at least you I want to check an EMF meter to see how many EMS you're getting from those things
And I don't know that
Something like that in itself could be interrupted your sleep
But getting sleep is very important. So you do want to investigate what could be hindering your sleep
And
Gosh, there's a myriad of things that could hinder our sleep
Certainly things in our diet could hinder our sleep certainly things that are troubling us emotionally
Could hinder our sleep
Okay, so I'm using it in government not an apple watch
I would just you know if you have an EMF meter just look at that
And check that and if you don't have a trifield meter or an EMF meter
Think about talking to asking around if any of your failure members have them because anybody who doesn't any electrical work would have a trifield meter
And just checking to see how much you know how much EMFs are coming off of that thing. You know, I don't know. Maybe nothing but just it's a good thing to check
And then look at things that could be disturbing your sleep
You know, if you're if you have excess cortisol
That's going to disturb your sleep and you're not you're going to be waking up a lot if you're not getting your oxygen
So maybe the position of your head
Could be disturbing your sleep or your pillow your
Might need to be cropped up a little bit at night. There's a lot of different things that can affect your sleep
Certainly your diet before you go to bed. There's certainly a lot of different herbs that a person could take to help them calm down
certainly
Looking at the TV before you go to bed is
Something you want to address to because like I said all screens
I'm looking at my computer screen right now and you are looking at yours probably is
It's
Emitting 60 Hertz so you're basically by looking at your screen or looking at a TV or looking at your phone before you're going to bed
Before you go to sleep, you're basically a training your brain at 60 Hertz
And then you have to get down to about 11 Hertz your brain waves in order for you to get get to sleep and sleep well. So
Just think about those things
That to help you sleep because it's very important that you're getting your sleep
I recently have had some very concerning numbers on my
complete metabolic panel
So it's a blood test complete metabolic panel
Alconphosphatase is 287. I think
Lamb ranges of alcohol and phosphatase
Turns out with lab, but most lab ranges the high is like 140
But really the functional range for Alconphosphatase high range is more like
You know 125 some people would even say you know
About the high range should be like 100. So I
Would
You know when did you have what happens? What would that be a sign up? What would elevated Alconphosphatase be a sign up?
Well, you have to look at it in
The picture in the bigger picture with other things
So here you gave me a couple other signs your AST and your ALT are both elevated
So Alconphosphatase is released by multiple tissues AST and ALT is really only from your liver
So when Alconphosphatase is elevated along with AST and ALT
It gives you a clue that it could be your liver
So what could cause Alconphosphatase AST and ALT to elevate in
From the liver
most common thing would be
The use of medications so drugs have to detoxify
through the phase one phase two cytochrome P450 and AT pathways in the liver and
can
Overwhelmed the liver and cause inflammation of the liver and cause
elevation of Alconphosphatase AST and ALT. That's the most common thing
Other things can be other issues with one's liver. So someone you know
Not anybody on this call, but somebody could have alcoholic liver syndrome. They're because they're drinking alcohol
You know, they're they're taught their liver is toxic due to other things
So liver you know liver failure it can liver markers can be elevated as well
so
But there's other things that can raise Alconphosphatase. So if Alconphosphatase was elevated
AST was normal and ALT was normal
then you would be thinking of
Issues with the bone especially given a history of cancer
What when a person has metastasis to bone and bode destruction
Bode can release Alconphosphatase so a person could have elevated Alconphosphatase because of bode destruction
Because of metastasis to bone, but it would spare the liver markers
So the AST and the ALT would be within normal range
But so the other thing that could raise Alconphosphatase
And it would raise AST and ALT is if there's bile destruction or bile obstruction
So there's so your liver sends
the toxins that are
funneled through the liver and and
Produced as an end product of detoxification of the blood
Sends it what's those toxins into the bile and then the bile goes through the bile duct down into the duodenum
It combines with the pancreas in the common bile duct
Goes through your gallbladder and then goes into the first part of the small intestine called the duodenum
if there's a blockage anywhere along that way
In blockage in the gallbladder, a blockage in the
comma bile duct, a blockage in the bile duct in the liver
That would also elevate Alconphosphatase AST and ALT
So those are the things that you'd want to
Figure out now if a person is like, okay, these were within normal range
Um, and they were having creepyed up since I started chemo
Okay, then you'd be like
Okay, well then that you know that could be the cause of it
typically if there's
bile obstruction you may also have elevated bile ruin
Um, so you'd want to look at other markers as well so you have to
any one marker can mean lots of different things
um, and the what they how will you help discern that is looking at other things as well
So I'd want to look at the rest of your blood work as well
Like I said Alconphosphatase is going to be typically elevated with bony destruction
But a person could have bony destruction and some issues with the liver at the same time
Then you want to also look at calcium levels
So you cast if there's bony destruction that's fairly aggressive
Then you're also going to have elevated calcium levels
So you've got to look at the big picture as much as possible
And then you don't just look at blood you look at the person symptoms
uh subjective things and you also look at other tests that are done so
uh if
If we do the total cause of this
Then we could answer this next part of the question
Is there anything I could do to diet diet wise to improve these numbers
Well, number one doing coffee enemies could be uh your best friend because
We know that there's liver involvement with AST and ALT. We just don't know why
If it is some bile duct obstruction coffee animals are going to help with that
Uh doing castorial packs over the liver could also be a good thing
That's why we recommend those things because they're good for you know multiple different causes of issues
So if it's bile duct obstruction if it's issues with inflammation in the liver
If it's issues with detoxification in the liver because it's becoming overwhelmed because I'm trying to detox
keyboard therapy or something coffee animals and uh
Castorial packs over the liver are going to do nothing but help that flow
So foods that could help these things again it depends or helping support liver pathways is best we can
Artichoke uh is a great thing for liver pathways beat root is great thing for liver pathways
So those are some things that I just thought I would stop my hand there
So
Answer the question best want to look at the whole big picture
To help deserve as best as possible
You know why these numbers are elevated
We're looking at my blood test and tuber markers which one is most important
So um a lot of people will get tuber markers done
Um and if you got them done through us I have
Put together the female tuber marker panel and the male tuber marker panel
Now again what are tuber markers? There are proteins
That cancers can give off now the operative word there is can or may give off. Maybe that's better um grammar
They may
Certain cancers may expel these different proteins and then we can measure them
But they don't always you can have stage 4 raging cancer and not show any positive lab test
elevations of tuber markers
Why but I don't know it's just as what it is
But it can be used uh if you do show elevations in tuber markers with your cancer
It can be used as another objective scale that you can measure progress in any
course of care
So well which ones are most important well it partly depends on what type of cancer you have
So the female tuber marker panel is my remember off the top of the head it's CA 15-3
Now CA 15-3 is only going to really show up in breast cancer
CA199 CA199 can show up in breast cancer but it's a primary marker of pancreatic cancer
CA 25-27 or 27-29 that's only going to be
Well, it's usually going to be just
breast cancer
CEA is um
Can be across multiple different cancers and CA 125 which could also be
Positive and multiple different cancers which one is most important and there is it one that's most important
So it's whichever one shows up on you and we want to use that as a marker
um
Well, what if this shows up and this doesn't what this one went up and this one went down
Uh again, you're just using those as clues to what's going on remember any blood test any test is just a clue
It's just giving us clues of what could be going on you're helping that with
Looking at other objective and subjective data to come up with the differential diagnosis of which direction you think the cancer is going
And what interventions might be the wisest to take
So there isn't the cancer marker or tumor marker that's more important than the other
Um, we're just looking at changes in that
When should I do another cheek swab test? I am doing really well and my oncologist told me
I don't need to return for six months, but I want to stay healthy
Well, you know, I actually created a video on when should I do another cheek swab test?
I think it's on the member site and stuff, but
Generally you do another cheek swab test if you like you'd want to like
Why do you go to the doctor?
Well, you want to go to the doctor to stay healthy and run some tests and
Make sure you're doing the right thing
But you don't go to the doctor every week to make sure you're doing the right thing
You typically go to the doctor on a regular basis maybe
If you're like me, you'd never go to the doctor, okay, but so maybe that's a bad example
But when do you run blood tests? You know, well, it depends
I have a serious thing going on so I might run blood tests on a monthly basis
I might run blood tests every two weeks if I have a serious anemia that I need to
To be in control of
I might do be doing well and they're stable
So I might run them every three months same thing with the cheek swab test
I'm really doing great
But maybe your inquiry is I'm doing really well
And I want to cut down on my supplements and just talk to somebody the other day
I'm doing really well and I'm you know getting supplement overload here
I want to cut back and get more specific
Well, let's do another cheek swab test and see what we can you know put in order and if there's
Anythings we can eliminate or I could put them in
Baby order of importance, you know for financial reasons
Totally understandable. So I would use it that way
Um, I think that makes the most sense
Is it bad to be using my cell phone while using the rice machine
Well, I'd say yes and no, I mean
Um, I don't think it's interfering with the rice machine, but I do think
um, I
Don't think that it's necessarily a good thing
So you're using your cell phone. You got data flying into your cell phone. That's
With a very strong signal
I already mentioned before. I don't think it's a great idea to be using your cell phone or before you go to bed
Because you're trading your brain at 60 hertz
But more than that you're putting your your
You're causing a lot of UMFs to traverse traverse your system
And that is not necessarily good either and we can't ignore the damage of EMFs
And it does to our body just because we can't see that measure it very well
So I would say probably not a great idea to use your cell phone while you're doing the rice machine
It's about having balance of course
But most of us have our cell phone glued to our hand out and we just have to be aware of that
Question case it okay to use the right machine while also doing cast oil packs
Yes, yes, for sure it is a benefit I think it might even be better
Um to be running the right volume with cast oil packs because you're stimulating the cancer cells at the same time you're
Doing cast oil that's
Exorbitated how we pull toxins out of your liver. I mean I think there could be
Um a good degree of frequency interchange there that could be
Healthful. So I think that's can be good
Can I take glue to style I have breast cancer in my chiropractor recently tested me and wants me to take it um
The answer is um it depends really so if you have breast cancer, but you're in full remission and
You feel like you've really conquered that
Um, can you take glutathione? I would say yeah, I'd say you could probably go back to taking some antioxidants
But if you have breast cancer and you're still dealing with the breast cancer
You would feel like you haven't totally conquered this and you're concerned about growth and you're considering with you know
Still you're not over it that you shouldn't be taking antioxidants. So
um
Of course, there's multiple different theories behind this and I've been on both sides of the fence of the fact
um, but if we're using
So I talked to somebody the other day that
Can't remember who it was, but they went and did uh, we're doing IV
Vitamin C with somebody who was a clinician who was gonna treat them for their cancer
And they're doing IV vitamin C IV glutathione and something else that was an antioxidant as well. I can't remember
So they were doing
I mean vitamin C remember at the dose that you'd get IV vitamin C anywhere above 10 grams, which typically will be getting
That would be a low starting dose of IV vitamin C
um
If you take vitamin C orally
Yeah, typically about 500 to 2000 milligrams a day
That's an antioxidant that's gonna have antioxidant effects on you
High dose vitamin C is gonna be oxidative. That's why it kills cancer. Low dose vitamin C is not gonna be cancer killing
It will stimulate your immune system so secondarily it can help
But it's also vitamin C at that dose functions as an antioxidant
Now if you if this is new information. I have written a blog post called hearticine
Hearticine oxidative stress to kill cancer. I think the type for the blog post if you go search that out
um cancer cells are reproducing
Cells that are not really healthy because they're rapidly replicating. They're already
um have a
higher level of oxidative stress and this is what
You're you're betting on when you do chemotherapy. So you're doing chemotherapy. You're taking out a toxin
Which is an oxidized agent
Which will tip over cancer cells before they'll tip over healthy cells
And those cancer cells will die therefore
The idea of chemotherapy is we're gonna give this person enough chemotherapy to kill the cancer but not enough to kill the patient
Meeting that we're gonna try to spare as many healthy cells as possible
Even though we're damaging healthy cells because we're we're giving them this oxidizing agent
Well, interesting enough nutritional oxidizing agents like high dose vitamin C
Don't damage healthy cells. They're not causing an oxidative stress state to a healthy cell
They're only causing an increase oxidative stress state to a cancer cell
Which is already at a highly you know an elevated
oxidative stress state or you could say more near its lethal desk dosage of oxidative stress
So you're basically adding a little bit more toxin to that
cancer cell
A.k.a oxidative stress to that cancer cell that's already near its lethal dose of oxidative stress
There might kill you the cancer cell
So if you're taking glutathione you are in effect
keeping cancer cells
From dying from oxidative stress because that's that is the very reason why cancer cells
Are in an elevated oxidative stress state is because they're mitochondria
Because they're rapidly replicating their mitochondria can't produce enough glutathione
To get rid of the oxidative stress that exists within the cytoplasm of the cancer cell
So when you take glutathione you could have be effectively keeping a cancer cell
alive you're effectively
Uh giving CPR to your cancer cells that you're trying to kill
With other measures. So
Most alternative cancer therapies whether you're taking b17 or
SCAC or
medicinal mushrooms or
You know you go on name it all these cancer therapies that we're doing on you are oxidative
So they're doing the same thing
Physiologically as as chemotherapy is doing
Without the negative effects of chemotherapy because chemotherapy doesn't spare healthy cells
Whereas a nutritional approach I mean person is healthy could take layatrol could take b17 and it's not going to cause cancer
But if person's healthy takes chemotherapy they're going to get really super sick
Why cuz they have all this cell lysis because you're killed your poisoning healthy cells
um, so
You don't want to take antioxidants when you're
Whether you're trying to kill cancer cells. So
Very long answer. I apologize
For no, I would disagree with your current partner. You know, I get this a lot not to bash other practitioners
They're trying very hard to help people, but
To cancer is totally different than everything else
The things that you would do to keep a person from getting cancer
Would be the exact opposite things you would do if you already have a cancer diagnosis the things you would do for cardiac support
You wouldn't do if you had an diagnosis of cancer. So there's some things in the natural
nutritional
Functional medicine, atroopathic
Et cetera, et cetera world that they learn then I've learned
That you have to rethink what you're thinking about
Helping somebody with cancer. It's just it's just different because
You know, it's just the different disease. So you have to think differently
Okay, questions from the chat
having energy
All day for different things
ATP in cells are working good
So if you have energy all day for different things does that mean your
cells are producing
A lot of ATP
Yeah, I would say so yeah, but there's other reasons why a person wouldn't have energy
So you can't just say because I have tired tired
My my mitochondria don't produce ATP. That's why so I really need to boost my mitochondria
No, I mean you got to look at why am I tired do I have anemia?
Do I have a growth of cancer if I had a cancer diagnosis do I have something all serious going?
I do I have liver congestion do I have detoxification issues do I you know there's
Food sensitivities and inflammation there's just a lot of different reasons why a person would not have energy
But could you say because I have energy my mitochondria working well? Oh, yeah, I guess you could you know
As I can walk up today my you know, I can breathe my lungs are functioning well. It doesn't mean they could be functioning better
Yeah, yeah, I don't know, but yes
How to clean
Zumbi cells in the blood I don't know what zombie cells are so what you have to clarify that
I
I'm using a garment okay
So I wouldn't say if you're using any a device on your body
It's really good to just check it with an EMF meter
You certainly don't want to be using a device thinking that it's healthy for you and it's actually just adding to your EMF load
If someone wants to get a malgum fillings removed do you feel it's really important to have this done by a dentist that specializes in this
We haven't had the best of luck with a dentist that specializes in this and it was very costly
So we are considered having a regular dentist who we are very happy would do this any suggestions or thoughts
Yes, I do have thoughts on that. So if your regular dentist is gonna take out
I am assuming you're saying a mercury fillings you have the silver a mercury mercury filling
So if you just have a regular a malgum filling like a white filling that you're gonna have removed because it needs to be replaced
You don't have to worry about that at all, but if you're getting a mercury filling removed silver filling
You do have to take precautions
Um you do then the precautions that should be taken is that you should have a you should have a rubber dam
And they should be very careful that they're suctioning up any silver that is broken off the tooth is there replacing it so that you're not swallowing it
Number two you should have they should have a mercury vacuum because when they're drilling out the mercury filling
It's gasifying and you're just breathing it right in and you'll get it in your system faster
That way then if you swallowed it if you swallow the mercury
You have a you have a decent chance if you have a healthy gut
A healthy gut lining that you won't absorb it and you'll deposit it into the toilet
If you breathe it in you're gonna it's gonna go right across the alveolar space
So gasified mercury is readily transferred into the blood and that's the biggest hindrance
So they need to have a mercury vacuum
And then lastly they should put a nasal cannula over your on your nose
So you're breathing in that nasal cannula and then put a wet wash rag folded up over your nose
So you're not breathing in any of that
Now you'll obviously be breathing through your mouth when your when your mouth is open
And you there's it's inadvertently you're gonna absorb some of that mercury. So you do want to be taken a key later
Um, which is you know my favorite is our keyla clear
Uh, I think it's phase zero keyla clear
Um, which has got dms a
EDTA and several other things in there to key like that out
So if you're if you're a current doctor who you really like will take those measures
They don't have to be listed as a biological dentist
Um, they just you just want to make sure they're taking those measures
If it's not a silver filling that you're talking about then you don't have to worry about any of those things
No elevated billy room and okay, that's very good. That's usually a sign that it's not a blocked
bile duct
Not always perfect wherever labs aren't always perfect
EGCG and sulfurophane are known phytochemicals that in part block metabolic pathways
Um, not sure
I am saying this correctly for cancer stem cells
Often I hear that whole foods that contain these
nutrients are said to be best, but I find I rely on supplements far more is that okay
Um, so EGCG sulfurophane
Um, and you could add curcumin tumeric to that you could add
You could really add
Most of the flavonoids to that um are are good things that that blocked cancer stem cells also you're going to practice all C to that
Um, and can can you get them in foods um, I would say
I would say not not usually so you could get like tumeric you could grind up your old tumeric and make tumeric um, you know
Juiced tumeric that would be really good
You're never going to get enough sulfurophane in foods. I'll guarantee you that as you're never going to get enough EGCG in foods
Um, I remember looking at the data a few years ago you'd have to drink on a pure organic green tea
You'd have to drink like 30 glasses of green tea in order to get
enough EGCG in one capsule of a typical EGCG
I think we're compared it to to me go at that time
The other day I'll say about EGCG and sulfurophane so EGCG you have to make sure that you get
Really good company. That's why I really like US enzyme because I went to their facility and they are like
Crazy anal about the purity of their EGCG. I know some other companies are really good with that too
But there's so much garbage EGCG is the most toxic imported
Um product and there is not EGCG on the market in the United States. It doesn't come from China
Which is fine, you know, it doesn't mean it's bad that it's coming from China, but
It means that it can be so there's a lot of corrupt sellers of products
Um that sell to even good settlement companies that if they're not
tested
With their own labs their product and they're not they're not upright in that then
They're it's not a good product. So there's there's several companies US enzyme
a premier research
decides for health is good with their testing
um
As antigens good for their testing
But um and then sulfurophane is another thing
So forophane has to be the really right type. That's why we likes the US enzyme sulfurophane
also
Sybage and sulfurophane is the same. It's really a good form of sulfurophane
sulfurophane
Tuberative
Go ahead. I have been using US enzymes. I like that too because of what you said it and my sister says the same thing
uh as far as sulfurophane
There's uh you can sprout broccoli sprouts. Is that any value?
I think it is value. I just don't think you'll get enough with how much you can eat
Um, that's the issue with that
Um, I think turmeric I think you could for sure get enough because
That's just ground turmeric. What's on the market. So I think that you could get enough
Just fine with making your own
Juicy your own turmeric. It's just
This is not very fun to do that on a regular basis. It's terrible. Yes. It's not really yummy
Uh, okay. Is it okay to use the right fishing? We'll do a cast on packs. I answered that one
I'm going for my six-month visit with my ecologist and intend to ask him
For what I need for maintenance
How often should I get two markers done?
Let me answer that one first
Well, it depends. So if your tumor markers are again, it's just like blood work
Oh, why if your tumor markers are in your CDC and your complete metabolic panel is all in perfect range
It hasn't been in the past
Um, then you know, let's say we were doing it every month. Then we then I spread it to every two months
It looks really good. It's going to three months or four months and then we go to six months
Um, you know, and then you make decisions, you know, partly upon how you're feeling like
At least, you know, I haven't done. I have, you know, I know the doctor told me
I'm not supposed to get my blood test done for six months
But then your four months into it and let's hear you're just not feeling well
And it's been a few weeks. You don't feel well. Then you should go and get a test. Don't wait
So um with tumor marker tests again, those can change pretty fast
But you know, it's not like unless your insurance pay for it
I don't know that the doctor will
Order it unless there is some reason to order it
You can order it from us. They're like a hundred bucks or something like that
But still a hundred dollars if you don't need to do it. So it depends on
You know, what where it where they're at and how long they've been
Within normal range and such those are how you help make that decision
What kind of scans should I ask for? Well, that depends on how invasive
You're willing to be and how
You know, because the invasiveness of a scan if you're going to do an MRI
It's typically going to be with contrast. So you're going to have gadolidium
excess gadolidium over time and the issue can be a major issue
If you're going to do CT scan that's a lot of radiation. So as a pet scan a lot of radiation
So and again, it just depends you know
I have patients that are like I ain't doing any of those any more ever. I just don't need that time
I think that's not helping me recover. So it
And and I've had other patients like no, I just I need to know I need to know because um
You know, you can't ignore the emotional issues behind a serious disease. So everybody's going to make their own decision with that
But you know, you know doing you know
CT scans every six months or a pet scan every
Six months to a year just to satisfy curiosity is probably not very good for us. So
It should be based upon
other
Non or less invasive signs and symptoms. So your blood tests are within normal range. You're feeling great. No
We're not going to do another CT scan
uh, so
Just to make sure you know because they're invasive and
They're not good for us. So we should be listening to those things
Is an ultrasound bill felt valuable at all with having had a double mastectomy
Um, no
Maybe two other parts of your body who do an ultrasound to
Your axillary area your armpit areas if you're thinking that you have a mast there
Um, so but to the chest wall no
You're just going to see your ribs and things. I don't think that's going to be a value there
What about those whole body MRIs that don't require Galilean? Yes, that's called Probuvo
um
Your chair says it paid for that. So that's going to be all cash out of pocket
But those are excellent. That's what I had
So that was my last scan and it does last time I did that was
It'll be three years now this spring will be three years um and um so
um
Those are those are great. You know, there's only I don't know
Night of eight or night or something around the country so you'd have to travel to where it is
But uh you could self-schedule that make your own appointment to do that. So those are great. Those are called Probuvo
um
He has said those are still up in the air but
Do you have any insight so your ecologist has said those are still up in the air because they have an investigator
They're extremely
accurate um
Those are really good tests, but they're just
Because the insurance companies and because the because the insurance companies are tied so tightly to the
To the manufacturers of equipment and drug companies. There's no money to be made out of something. I haven't covered them yet
Um just getting regular blood work. I think is a good thing to do and it's something that is
Often overlooked and make sure you send it to me and make sure that we go over it on a fairly regular basis. I got somebody's blood work in
early last week and
They sent me their blood work. It was from September and
When I looked at it there was some abnormalities and I think I talked about this last two call but
Nobody ever talked about it. So
I see this you know way times I see this all the time where people get blood work done
And then why do you order the blood work if you don't talk to the person about the blood work so
If you're gonna send me blood work
It's your responsibility just to make an appointment with me to schedule to talk about it if you if I didn't order it
So if I did it order your blood work and you got them from your ecologist
I'm kind of making the assumption that they discuss these things with you
Which is really a stupid assumption?
I'm finding so
But if you want somebody to go over it. I'm gladly go over with you, but I don't want to sound like I'd like
You know wishing you for office visits or something like that
I want you to know what's going on in your blood work. So you can help
discern
Your course of care and what's going on with you and
also look at
Product disease and autoimmune course because I have a lot of videos on helping
Understand some different blood work
um, that could be helpful for you as well to self understand them
Next question. I have surgery scheduled for 1230 to take down my
Iliostomy which will be fantastic. Yes
Since I have been very in decisive regarding chemo and I've not done it
My surgeon is very concerned because I have elevated
Uh, the signature CT DNA results she wants to do
A CT at a colonoscopy next week prior to the surgery
I suspect that may be a good idea in general
They hinted that they may advise postpone surgery depending on the results of those procedures
Well, sure they're going to because if there's an issue then they're going to want to try to take care of that first
Right, so that makes sense. Those are all reasonable requests. I think by your ecologist. So
Uh
While I was
eligible to take down the iliostomy mid-September, I couldn't because the local surgeon was
Wasn't available eating
So I think those are reasonable requests by the surgeon. So yes
So yes, a mercury filling so that I would take those precautions that I had stated
Another name for a zombie cells are
Cinescent cells
Okay, so you're talking more functional medicine language there and you're talking about
um
Helping
With uh process called autophagy
So autophagy is that function in your body where you're getting rid of or sluffy the cells away
Uh
You know there's there's um
There's different nutrition that is what when there's new things discovered in functional medicine
There's typically a new
Product that it it'll some companies will come out with there's a product from php called autophagy assist and
um uh
For that
Purpose
Uh, oh, I'd be careful with jumping into those things as most people are already doing
Everything you need to do to help get rid of
toxins and get rid of
um, you know helping support autophagy and helping support
um detoxification pathways
It's just like oh, I learned about uh, you know, should I be taking
You know this and I want to do a detox
uh protocol
Well the truth is you're already doing a detox protocol. It's not about
You know jumping on a bandwagon to do
Something new because that's gonna solve my problems
It's something you're doing every day if you're not detoxifying
You are dying so
Yes, you want to support these pathways. So again, you go back to how do I support
Everything's got to everything in your tissues if it's gonna get into the blood
It has to go through the liver
Through the bile duct into the gallbladder into the duodenum into the toilet. That's how you get rid of things
Now you can support detoxification via other pathways
By doing sodas and helping sweat
And we do recommend people doing those things
But ultimately supporting the liver is the key because that's going to be the bottle neck of everything. So
uh
Well, you go all the way around to coffee and it was a castoral packs again, don't we?
so um
Helping support liver function helping support bio flow
That's what it gets down to making sure you're binding things in the gut making sure you're having really good bowel movements
Every day it probably animals will help with that. So
Kind of comes full circle
Did you explain that people with cancer should not take antioxidants
Like vitamin C, vitamin E, etc
um
But they can use those same things in a very high dose
Um, the answer to that is yes
But the very high dose doesn't actually have to be very high
I mean you don't have to go to 10 grams of vitamin C for it to be oxidative
But you really have to get up to at least
three four five grams of vitamin C
Vitamin E it's even less than that. So normally let's say
You know like the a poppy we have of our store
Um, taking even two or three of those is that an oxidative dose
So uh, it's it's it's if you know put it this way if you're if you're just getting your vitamin E from your food
It's having some antioxidant effect and don't get me wrong
Food that you're eating has antioxidants in it. Okay, you do need a level. It's not it's about balance. Okay
You just want in a state of cancer you want your balance to be tipped more towards pro oxidative as far as the nutrition
Supplements you're taking it
Not as far as the toxins that you're consuming but as far as supplements
So um, you know, you are getting antioxidants through I ate some broccoli today
So um that is helping your other cells
So it's not like you're emptied all antioxidants from consumption
That's very possible
But this from a supplement standpoint you don't want to be supporting the health of cancer cells
So um, I hope that helps and read read that article too. I think that will be helpful too
I was talking about the whole body MRIs
That they have at salamid med for $600 cash post
I don't think it's the same as predubo
I'm not familiar with those um, whole body MRIs that they have at salamid med I'm not familiar with what salamid med is
Um, and I it if they are a whole body MRI
without gadolinium
That give you the data
That will give you know that you need it's all that's fantastic. So um, and that's a really decent price. So
So it's five to 10 grams of vitamin C pro oxidative
Yes, yes, even I would say you don't even go to 10 grams
But again, it's like oh well, you have to take it all at once
So it's like well, I take a five grams. I take a thousand milligrams
capsule every three hours throughout the day
Well
No, then you're not you're not getting you're getting antioxidant effect because it's it's you're getting that absorbed at a thousand milligrams
And then you are you know, that's you know, it's because a half-life in your body
And it's pretty much gone before you take your next dose
So no, you're getting very strong antioxidant effect of vitamin C
So you need to take it all at once to get that effect
Should you have something in your stomach when you take vitamin C? Yeah, I'm not even so understand I'm not telling people to take five grams of vitamin C
Um
Because that can be very upsetting. It's the city can can
And if you have issues with your stomach every typically if you took five grams of vitamin C you're getting a stomach acid stomach pain
um
Could be because you already have a decrease um
Uh in the hydrochloric acid your stomach
so uh
That's something to look at so hypochloridria, but yeah, you could take it with food for sure
All right, where were we here?
I think
This entire time even before my surgery, I was muscle tested for glutathione greens
Those immune packs. I think it's applicable with NAC and it right some people are so you know if you're tested for that
And I'm comfortable as you're taking that I think you're fine, but I think that you know
You just it have you have to be sure with that so you're exactly right
Any other questions?
Dr. honey take a reord clinic take 16 grams daily all at once for an interview with him
That's funny um
Most people wouldn't want to take that. I mean it unless you got like um
Maybe you guys like fourth
Absels some kind of special buffered vitamin C. I don't know what it is. Okay. Yeah
So buffered vitamin C just has some like minerals in it so it's not quite as acidic of a slay about your stomach
Yeah, I mean certainly if you could get a high dose of vitamin C
It's a whole lot less expensive than going to do it a $300 IV infusion
Um the next the other thing is that you remember you're not gonna you're not going to absorb
necessarily if you took 16 grams all the once you may only be absorbing
You know
10 grams of it. I don't know but everybody's different
But you know you you're not going to absorb necessarily everything that you're going to swallow too
That's the advantage of liposomal
That's typically you'll get like five times the absorption rate that's liposomal so
Well, I was doing it across the whole day
So I'm so glad you told me about that because between liposomal and regular vitamin C
I could probably do five or six grams all at once without a problem. I think it's better to do it all at once
Okay, thank you
All right, we'll take you guys a good zoom call today. We will
Be back next week
Hope everybody's getting all their Christmas shopping done and you have a blessed next
This coming week and we'll see you then
Bye-bye everybody